this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and i'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my nemesis i've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device called the pod pro cover
by eight sleep it's the easiest and
fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced but most user-friendly
solution on the market i polled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this so i used it and here we
are add the pod pro cover to your
current mattress and start sleeping as
cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot
as 110 degrees fahrenheit it also splits
your bed in half so your partner can
choose a totally different temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need cooling she loves the heat
and we can have our own bespoke
temperatures on either side which is
exactly what we're doing now for me and
for many people the result eight sleep
users fall asleep up to 32 percent
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40 and get more restful sleep overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution for enhanced recovery so
you can take on the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250 off of
the pod pro cover that's a lot simply go
to eight sleep dot com slash tim or use
code tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use coupon
code tim t-i-m-eight sleep dot com slash
tim for 250 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by
headspace headspace is your daily dose
of mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations in an easy to use app now
you might ask yourself very reasonably
there are 2 000 plus apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research headspace is backed by 25
published studies on its benefits 600
000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million downloads so if people keep
telling you to try meditation and you're
like when would i do that when would i
possibly have time you should check out
headspace if you have 10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers a really light lift and a lot of
features to keep you going which is part
of the reason that i've used headspace
for years now so whatever the situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation for you need
some help falling asleep headspace has
wind down sessions that are members
swear by and for parents headspace even
has morning meditations you can do with
your kids headspace's approach to
mindfulness can reduce stress improve
sleep boost focus and increase your
overall sense of well-being and it
really starts with very very simple
practices and if you look at my case for
instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the
co-founder andy i think it's puddicum
could be putty comb i'm not sure but
former monk turned into co-founder of
headspace has the most soothing hypnotic
voice imaginable and i did a three
minute meditation something like that
it's easy it's fundamental and it always
puts me in a better space so i'm going
through the basics even though i've
meditated for years i'm going through
the basics once again and i would
suggest to anyone that they consider
starting there headspace makes it easy
for you to build a life-changing
meditation practice with mindfulness
that works for you on your schedule
anytime anywhere we all want to feel
happier we all want more peace and
headspace is meditation made simple go
to headspace.com
tim that's headspace.com tim for a free
one month trial with access to
headspace's full library of meditations
for every conceivable possible situation
you can break glass in case of emergency
in almost any situation and find
something on headspace this is the best
deal offered right now for headspace so
check it out go to headspace.com
tim
today at this altitude i can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking can i ask you a personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal and those skeletons
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today is dr sue johnson you can find her
on twitter at dr underscore sue johnson
she is a leading innovator in the field
of couples therapy and adult attachment
she is the primary developer of
emotionally focused couples and family
therapy known as eft which has
demonstrated its effectiveness in more
than 30 years of peer-reviewed clinical
research we will talk about this sue has
received numerous awards in recognition
of her development of eft including the
american psychological association's
family psychologist of the year and the
order of canada her best-selling book
hold me tight with more than one million
copies sold that's very hard to do has
taught countless couples how to enhance
and repair their love relationships the
book has since been developed into a
relationship enhancement program called
hold me tight online her most recent
book for clinicians attachment theory
and practice delineates the promise of
attachment science for understanding and
repairing relationships as the founding
director of the international center for
excellence in emotionally focused
therapy sue trans counselors and eft
worldwide and provides guidance to 80
affiliated centers she consults for the
us and canadian militaries and is a
popular presenter and speaker for the
general public you can find more on sue
and her work at doctor sue johnson.com
that's drew johnson.com
dr johnson welcome to the show oh hey
i'm delighted to be with you tim thank
you for inviting me
i am
also thrilled to have you and we have an
abundance of questions in front of me we
may cover some of them i don't okay
i don't get too attached to trying to
cover them all because we'll run out of
time but i thought we would start with
something that was mentioned in
the intro and that i know will interest
my audience and that is
the peer-reviewed clinical
research or research depending on where
you happen to be in the world could you
speak to the actual science and research
related to your work there's now over 20
outcome studies outcome studies in
psychotherapy are very hard to do
and there's a lot of noise in the system
there's lots of things going on in
people's lives you know
life gets in the way so
you have to work very hard to get
results
and
follow-up is the real the real thing
that matters
and i we are the only couple
interventioned as far as i know
that has the size of results we get
that impacts people the way we do that
knows why we get these results i can
tell you exactly what needs to happen in
therapy to get the results
and that gets fantastic follow-up
we can work with a couple for
14 to 20 sessions
we can look at them at the end of
therapy
we can see that they are happier more
secure
more securely bonded
their sex life is better they feel less
depressed as individuals and we followed
them up three years later and the
results hold
which is
just so that everyone knows
astounding the latest one we're doing is
we've got a great big one with the heart
institute in ottawa
because
the uh cardiologists have realized that
actually if their patients have good
relationships
with their partners they're much less
likely to have another heart attack they
take their meds they go to the gym
so then they said well could you do
something and we said okay are you
kidding we'll design a 16-hour program
for you and we'll research it
so we're doing that
but to be honest
i do the research because we learn and
because it's our way of testing what we
think we know
but it's not what really turns me on in
the end what turns me on
is watching these couples learning from
them and watching them make these huge
changes in their lives i've been doing
it for 35 years
and it turns me on
like i dance argentine tango it turns me
on like the best malonga ever and
dancing with the best partner ever okay
so i have many follow-ups of course as
questions just as a side note i lived in
argentina from 2004 to 2005 and went to
milonga
probably five or six times a week hey
did a lot of tangos so we have that in
common aha and if we focus just for a
few more minutes on the research because
this will be a way of backing into
defining eft for folks i think so i've
read that eft has something like a like
73 to 86 success rate in studies with
distressed couples and yes
i would love to know what
or how success is
defined in these studies i think that
would be helpful for people listening
and okay
then later we'll return to the
durability of effect because that's
incredible that you're doing follow-ups
three years later and seeing that
persistence of effect is really
incredible but how do you define success
with distressed couples that's a good
question and it depends on the study but
in general
we define it with a measure of it's
called marital adjustment
and it basically looks at the couple's
take perception of
their marital satisfaction it's a bit
more than satisfaction because it has
different elements to it so we use a
scale that's been used in all kinds of
research that's got all kinds of
validity
but we've also used all kinds of
measures the one that i think is the
most interesting
is that we did a big study a few years
ago looking not just at whether we can
help you change your marital
satisfaction your adjustment
the way you see your partner
we can help you change the security of
your bond
with your partner which for me is
much more significant
than satisfaction or saying yes we have
an adjusted marriage you know we have a
good marriage i trust this person in
this marriage to be able to say
we have a more secure bond
and we know how to create that bond
ongoingly in the future
that still amazes me that we know that
because we've talked in our society
forever
about how romantic love is this great
mystery and it just sort of comes and
hits you in the head you fall in you
fall out there's nothing much you can do
about it well actually that's rot now
and personally i think it should be all
over the front of the new york times
we've cracked the code of love but the
new york times doesn't agree with me so
i think that's real big news for people
when we can show in our study which we
did
that we can take people
very distressed people who don't trust
each other who can't talk to each other
who aren't intimate
and we can in 20 sessions
create
a bond where they can turn and be
vulnerable with each other and they can
say i trust this person i'm close to
this person i can be open to this person
this person is my special one i trust
this relationship
and they can do the things we can see on
tape they can do the things that secure
the attached people do in loving lasting
relationships
that's very significant we also find
things like depression goes down when
people are more securely connected with
each other anxiety goes down people deal
with trauma better
we see a lot of folks with ptsd
when you've faced dragons
to recover from that experience you need
to find comfort in the arms of another
and that's just the way we're wired
and if you cannot find comfort in the
arms of another
you are hard-pressed from my point of
view no matter how many times you
meditate no matter how many tips you've
learned no matter how much insight you
have
if you can't find comfort in the arms of
another to heal from trauma
it's bad news
so we have a lot of different results
but they're all on
measures that are accepted by the field
as valid they've all been in
peer-reviewed journals
and believe me
reviewers are
brutal to psychologists they're
brutal me ask a few questions if i may
jump in then right now we're going to
continue of course on the path to
defining what characterizes or
describing what characterizes eft what
scale do you use or scales do you use
when assessing marital satisfaction and
bond and just for those people listening
who may not know what we're talking
about they're different questionnaires
and scales for different types of
conditions for instance you might have
the ham d for depression you might have
cap 5 or caps 5 for ptsd
i'm sure some people will be curious if
there are any particular scales they
could find themselves just to look at
their own i believe i put some of those
scales in my book love sense actually we
use the dyadic adjustment scale which
has been used in marital research for
decades for adjustment
we use various things for things like
depression like the bec depression scale
for attachment we use something called
the experiences in close relationship
scale
which is used in adult adult attachment
research has only been going for the
last 20 years so it's young
attachment research was really confined
to mothers and children for decades
and the belief was that once you hit 12
you were supposed to become
self-sufficient so attachment didn't
matter very much but that's changed
so now we have a whole field called
attachment research and the experiences
in close relationship
scale
is the measure we use however
we have also used observational measures
like coding couples interactions as they
talk and we can talk about that we talk
about something called a hold me tight
conversation
we can code the behaviors are totally
different when they come into therapy
and when they're finished and my
favorite one
which i can't resist talking about
is that we did a brain scan study
with a wonderful colleague of mine from
the university of virginia called jim
cohn
neuroscientist
where we put the women we hadn't got
enough money to do both partners
so we had to choose so yes i know so we
put the women in an mri machine at the
beginning when they were distressed and
insecurely attached and didn't believe
that their partners loved them or cared
for them
we put the women in mri machine at the
beginning of therapy and then at the end
of therapy when they had these hold me
tight conversations
and we were a bit brutal when i think
about it
we put them in the mri machine and we
said when you see an x in front of your
face there's a good chance you're going
to be shocked on your ankles and it's
going to hurt
and it did hurt because we tried it on
my research assistant and she told us
very clearly
that it hurt okay so we turned the
machine down a bit but what was
interesting is at the beginning
before therapy before eft
we showed these women this x
and their brains went into immediate
alarm on the mri high high alarm state
because they're expecting the shock and
once we delivered the shock we asked if
it hurt and they said it was painful or
extremely painful
this is in a journal called plus one
and
after
sessions of therapy after eft
when they'd had these bonding
conversations by the way we put them in
and we since you're interested in
research i'll tell you a bit of detail
basically they saw the x when they were
alone in the machine when they held
their partner's hand when they were in
the machine and when a stranger held
their hand and before therapy in all
three conditions
their brains went berserk and they said
that the shock was extremely painful
after therapy we put them in the machine
again did the same thing they saw the x
when the stranger held their hand
or when they were alone in the machine
same thing as before their brain went
berserk and they said it was extremely
painful
this time after eft
and the bonding conversations when their
partner held their hand
reached into the machine and held their
hand their brain stayed completely calm
it looked like a resting brain it looked
like they were just resting there their
brains stayed completely calm and if you
ask them if the shock hurt they said it
was uncomfortable
and so i'm not a neuroscientist so i saw
these
brain scans and there was some blue
lighting up after therapy and i said to
my colleague jim what does the blue mean
i can't see any red for alarm anymore
but what does the blue mean
and he said it means they're not dead
sue
oh
okay so that's
so he said that's just resting brain oh
okay jolly good so
that spoke to me amazingly because
psychology is often dismissed as a sort
of soft science
and you know indeed we deal with many
intangibles
but for me that was incredibly neat
because you could see it and you could
see
that we're talking about biology here
but we're talking about the biology of a
social
being
a being whose brain is wired for
connection with other people
and who needs this connection with other
people to thrive and survive
love is an ancient wired in survival
code
we have all these silly misinformation
in our society silly what we call love
stories they're still out there
psychology puts out a lot of
misinformation
about love is some strange mixture of
sex and sentiment
no
romantic love is about bonding and it's
an ancient wide in survival code and you
could sure see it in these mris these
women's brains when they had this secure
connection with their partner
these women's brains were completely
different than in the beginning when
they felt no safe connection with their
partner so it was very very interesting
i would love to
dig into what sounds like the glue
involved in some of the
bond enhancement as demonstrated in the
follow-up fmri
and that is the hold me tight
conversation maybe this is a way also of
coming in sideways to
basically demonstrate what eft is or at
least a component of it could you walk
us through what a hold me tight
conversation is
a whole big tight conversation
very briefly is a bonding conversation
the tricky part is that as adults some
of us have never seen this conversation
so it's a dance that is foreign to us
we've never had it with our own parents
we've never had it with siblings we've
never had it with previous lovers
and we get married or we get committed
to a partner
and
it's reasonable that we don't know how
to go there because many of us it's just
not a drama that we've ever seen enacted
a homie tight conversation is where one
person is able to
open up and reach for the other person
and share vulnerabilities
talk about their needs and fears in a
way that pulls the other person close
it helps the other person reach back and
respond
could you give any examples of phrasing
or questions
or guidelines you provide that would be
i i know i would love to know and i
suspect others would too well when you
don't trust you don't feel safe and
you've never seen a hold me tight
conversation the way it usually goes
just naturally as human beings i catch
myself doing this with my husband if i'm
upset about something
like he's been going to bed very early
and that means that we don't have our
snuggle time we don't have a little chat
time okay and it doesn't seem to bother
him at all but it doesn't bother him
this isn't happening so this will go on
for a couple of weeks and
even though i'm doing this work there's
a certain point where i start to get
self-protective and i start to blame him
in my head and i say he's always too
busy he's got his lists he's got lists
that's what he and he's a man and he's
got lists and all he cares about is his
list of tasks and he's just into problem
solving and he doesn't think about me at
all and this dialogue will go in my head
so i turn to him and i say
you're going to bed very early
these days listen to my voice it's the
emotional music
he says no
no because he hears the threat in my
tone i say yes you are and you've been
going to bed for weeks and i guess it
doesn't matter to you that we're not
having those close moments uh listen to
me i mean i'm on the attack
and we are
acutely sensitive as human beings to
signs of rejection or abandonment by the
people we love acutely sensitive that's
how we're wired so he hears that he's
blown it he hears it that i'm rejecting
him i'm telling him he's done something
wrong so he says i don't want to talk
about this right now
i say oh let me guess you have to go to
bed because you're so tired
right so we're off right
okay that is the typical demand withdraw
demand defend
dialogue that you'll see in a distressed
couple
and it's totally predictable
you can also have it with your kids i
can remember a glorious argument i had
in starbucks with my adolescent son that
was just a perfect example of the way
distressed couples talk to each other so
i'm blaming and pointing fingers and
he's rolling his eyeballs and basically
telling me what a dreadful mother i am
so you can have it with anyone but with
partners it's very predictable and it
has everyone feeling completely
threatened and unsafe
and unable to dance together if you
shift that into a hold me tight
conversation the way it would go
is that i would be
more able to tune into my own needs
more aware of my own needs accepting of
my own needs
and i would realize
oh
i'm really missing those conversations
with john we've been married for 32
years we're both very strong people so
it's been quite an adventure so i think
oh i'm missing
those relationships with john
and maybe he doesn't miss them
and oh that makes me feel really somehow
anxious and uncomfortable if he doesn't
miss them
because
the big question in love relationships
is are you there for me do i matter to
you can i count on you
maybe those conversations don't matter
to him but they really matter to me
so i am aware on a different level
of me and i'm specifying that scares me
a bit that maybe these conversations
don't matter to him i can tune into my
own emotions then i take the risk
and reach for him and say to him i'm
open
i say to him
you know what we haven't been having our
usual talks late at night
and
somehow it doesn't look like you miss
them
and
somehow that makes me feel
kind of really sort of uncomfortable you
know it's almost feels
like i'm i'm not sure that that
closeness matters to you and
so
i could get angry about it but actually
what's happening is
it sort of scares me a bit because i
need those conversations now i've talked
about my fears and my needs
i can only do that if i have some sort
of model that it's okay to do that that
that doesn't mean i'm a wimp or mentally
ill
or weak
or pathetic from my point of view it's
strength to do that and that's what we
teach and it's strength to do that
and that's what securely attached people
can do they can reach from a position of
vulnerability so i say that to him
and that pulls him he says
oh
you're right
yeah
um
yeah
i really like those i really i do i do
want those conversations so i've just
been so exhausted and i've been doing
this and i haven't wanted to tell you
how stressed out i am
so then it becomes reciprocal i say oh
i didn't know that you were so stressed
out about this decision we've made and
that it's taking up all your energy and
you're worried about it so then we start
to have
an open responsive engaged conversation
where we can share vulnerabilities
comfort each other
and you're literally better at tuning in
to each other and i think that's because
when i feel safe
i can tune into you
when i think about the people i can
dance with in tango really well it's the
people i feel emotionally safe with and
i know that there's no mistakes because
mistakes don't matter we're just playing
then i relax i'm in my body i tune into
their cues and we move together
naturally so that's kind of what happens
and it's a hold me tight conversation
and it's
sort of cascades
each time you have this conversation
it's
your nervous system goes ah
this is comfort this is home this is
safety this is this is what i need and
you see your partner as a resource
you see your partner as somebody who can
provide this safety comfort caring
reassurance
social support if you want to use a
psychological formal term for it you see
your partner as this person and your
partner
connects and you know how to do this
dance this dance is innately
rewarding
it creates joy in people you don't have
to
persuade people to keep doing it like
going to the gym or meditation or their
communication skills
people will do this once they know how
to do it
they'll keep doing it and that's why i
think we get good follow-up results
because once you start having these
conversations
and
it's very moving sometimes to see
people's
response like people
will stop to cry and say things like
when they discover these hold me tight
conversations people will say
i'm thinking of one man who said
i never knew that you could talk to
somebody like this
i never knew
that you could
ask for these things and that she wants
me to be vulnerable to her i never knew
that i never saw that growing up i
didn't know people did that
and then he wept
and he turned to the therapist and said
i've been alone all my life haven't i
and that
what attachment science tells us is that
emotional isolation is toxic for human
beings
i mean we found out that in the pandemic
but
we still don't get it i wish we would
get it on a different level it's toxic
for human beings it's not who we are and
when people start to have these
hold me tight conversations
all kinds of amazing things happen they
don't just understand how relationships
can be and how you can shape
relationships don't have to just have
them happen to you you can shape love
they understand something very deep
about themselves
couples grow each other in safe
relationships
couples grow each other
i watch
severely traumatized people learn to
trust another human being by having
these homie tight conversations with
their partner
and it changes everything
because they have a secure place in life
for the first time they feel seen
they feel accepted they feel held
and once you feel seen accepted and held
there's a natural
human
growth process that happens
attachment or science is all about
development of the personality there's a
natural growth process so we tune into
that natural process in the whole me
tight conversation
and those conversations predict
over study after study after study after
study
those conversations predict success in
eft
they predict more secure bonding they
predict better sex
more sexual satisfaction in couples they
predict
any sort of
measure of
good positive functioning you can
imagine those bonding conversations
predict all the good results we get in
eft and they predict results follow up
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
layered superfood founded by big wave
surfer laird hamilton and volleyball
champion gabby reese layered superfood
that's l-a-i-r-d delivers high-impact
fuel to help you get through your
busiest days and i know these two people
they walk the walk i love their new
aloha oat mac you heard me right aloha
oatmak superfood creamer i use the
unsweetened version made from real
plant-based ingredients including
organic oats macadamia nuts that's where
the oat mac comes from avocado oil and
aquaman aquaman is a natural source of
seaweed derived calcium with 72 minerals
and trace amounts laird's creamers can
really optimize your daily coffee or tea
ritual i use them all the time and a 10
bag will last you a long time for a
limited time lyric superfood is offering
you guys my listeners 20 off when you
use code tim
20 at checkout that's tim20
visit
layeredsuperfood.com tim to see some of
my favorite products and learn more
again that's lairdsuperfood.com
tim l-a-i-r-d layered superfood.com and
use code tim20 for 20 off of your order
layeredsuperfood.com
tim promo code tim 20.
so i would love to ask more about the
hold me tight conversations and i'll
share a bit of
the
sort of context from which i'm asking
this so i
we don't necessarily have to get into
details we could but i had quite a bit
of a severe
early childhood trauma like
two to four and
have not only felt
largely alone my entire life but have
created isolation it's been uh constant
for me
and
so what you're saying about these
conversations
helping to create the feeling of
bondedness and
sort of counterweight perhaps someone's
historical tendency to isolate or feel
isolated
is really appealing i would love to
hear if you're open to sharing and
perhaps another
hypothetical
hold me tight conversation or other
phrases or questions
that are helpful for people who want to
get a better understanding of of what
this might look like
in real life
where we start with couples
many of whom have experienced being
alone most of their lives traumatized or
not where we start is we help couples
see the the dance they're caught in love
is a dance we help couples see the dance
they're caught in
we help couples see the negative
patterns the most popular one of all is
i become aware of the disconnection
between the two of us
i get worried about it it makes me
anxious
and i don't feel safe enough to turn and
really share my vulnerability so i
demand i blame
i tell you where are you what i'm really
saying is where are you where are you i
can't find you and that alarms me but
what i say is things like you don't talk
to me enough or you know you never tell
me how you feel
or you know if you're a man you'll say
you never tell me you want to make love
you don't ever show me you want me
what's wrong with you i said we turn to
our partner we say what's wrong with you
so we help couples see how they scare
the hell out of each other
and
create
even more insecurity
and
stop each other from being able to be
vulnerable and risk when they start to
see that it's the pattern that's the
problem the dancers problem
and the fact they they don't know how to
do a more positive dance
they start to blame the dance rather
than each other and they start to be
able to say hey we're stuck in that
thing we're stuck in that thing we do
where i shut down and shut you out and
you must be getting alarm right now and
the other person says yes i'm starting
to freak out and they say oh let's not
do that let's try and help each other
feel a bit more safe so we create that
platform first but then you have to
start where people are
and sometimes with a hold me tight
conversation with somebody who's been
very traumatized
and has all the reasons in the world
not to trust another human being
with the softness of their heart
all the good reasons in the world
you have to start there
i've worked with lots of traumatized
folks and you have to start with
somebody saying
i understand now the patterns and how
we've been caught in this dance
i understand that you aren't always
trying to hurt me
or have me prove myself to you or prove
me wrong
but i want to tell you
the idea of really opening up to you
and showing you who i am
just feels impossible i don't know how
to do it it's impossible i don't think i
can do it so you start where people are
you don't get people to do it in spite
of how they feel
you get them to trust their feelings my
experience is someone will say that and
i will say could you turn and tell your
partner please
i don't think i can do it
i don't think i can risk letting you
really see me
i'm so sure that you won't want me
or that you'll find some way to hurt me
then i don't know what would happen i
don't think i could tolerate it i don't
think i can do it
could you turn and tell her what i do is
i hold the person and i help them
speak their emotions
and say their emotions clearly
and i hold them in that i support them
in that so guy turns and tells his wife
and his wife says
and this is the amazing thing about
bonding
this is who we are we are empathic
creatures that empathy is blocked by all
kinds of other things but we are
empathic creatures my experiences the
partner will say
i never knew
that i just felt that you didn't want to
share with me
i never knew it was so hard
i never knew that it was scary for you i
never understood that
i can't believe
i understand i understand that
now you've helped me understand
how scary that is
i can't believe
that you're even here telling me this
and i love you for taking that risk
thank you for taking that risk
and then the door opens wider
and then i say
usually i say because we always have
this catastrophe in our head when we're
afraid we create catastrophes in our
head to try and prepare for them right
so i say what is going to happen if you
really show her who you are
and you show her how scared you are to
really open up and show your
vulnerability what is going to happen
and he says
she'll tell me what i've always known
she'll tell me that i'm weak
there's something wrong with me
and the reason that i've been alone all
my life is because there was something
wrong with me and the reason i was so
hurt when i was little was because i
wasn't a good enough kid
or a special enough kid
i didn't do it right
one lady broke my heart she said i was
so careful when i asked my mother for
attention i was so so careful i'd plan
it and plan it in the dark for hours
no matter how i did it it never worked
it never worked she was always angry at
me
so i said to myself
it's me it must be me
there's something wrong with me
i'm just not lovable
and she weeps
when she does that her partner reaches
for her naturally her partner reaches
for her and says
this vulnerability
when you really help people move into it
with safety evokes caring and compassion
it just does so then the partner moves
in and supports
and gradually gradually
the other person is able to open up it's
not something that you do once
it's not something that you can
do mechanically
you have to be involved in it and for
some of us
if we've been desperately hurt when we
were nidal
and we learned that that kind of
openness was desperately dangerous
it's like jumping off a cliff and you
have to respect that you have to respec
emotions are in no way illogical
that's one of the big mistakes we've
made in psychology they're in no way
logical they have their own logic
they're a supreme
information processing system that it
wires us to see the world in a
particular way to move in a particular
way and
we haven't taught people how to
understand them how to listen to them
and how they make sense they always make
sense
if someone's terrified of that kind of
openness
it's because they have very good reasons
to be
and often they haven't told their
partner
they haven't told their partner anything
about it so their partner has no idea
the partner says you just don't want to
be close to me
you just don't want me
no i do desperately want you i'm just
terrified to let you see me
in psychology we're very good at looking
at the behavior and the problem
and
sometimes i feel like we're not so good
at what we are supposed to be the
experts in which is looking underneath
the behavior and the problem and seeing
the emotional realities that push that
problem forward and keep people stuck in
that problem
i don't know if i answered you tim i
there's so much to talk about here i
tried to answer i think you did no you
did and i mean the the examples are just
heartbreaking and i think they're
heartbreaking i mean i was like feeling
myself getting really emotional is
because they resonate i think with so
many people they resonate with me i
should say but i suspect that these
types of situations are really really
common but when you're experiencing them
i think it's so easy to
view yourself
as uniquely flawed in some ways
yes but it's so common it's so common it
seems so common at least i mean you'd be
more qualified to speak to it i think it
is common and i think the power of
attachment science is
it tells us who we are
it tells us that we are social beings
wired for connection we need safe
connection with others to survive and
thrive dependency became a dirty word
somewhere through our history
and we all fell in love with the image
of the lone cowboy writing over the
range the eagles song desperado i love
that song it's my favorite song because
it basically takes the image of the lone
cowboy and basically says buddy you
better find someone to love you because
you're in deep trouble
[Laughter]
so
so it it takes this strong image and
says no you're in trouble and dependency
became this dirty word
and
i think what attachment science says is
we are interdependent human beings
wired for connection with others from
the cradle to the grave and
when you present that
to people not the way i just said it
which is abstract you know when you
move people into that reality and you
accept it and say of course this is who
we are as human beings and we all get
stuck here and we all need this
people go
oh
oh you mean i'm not crazy bad
deficient defective unlovable
no no you're not you're just a human
being who needs
that connection with another human being
and who is terrified of rejection and
abandonment and the reason you're
terrified of rejection and abandonment
is because those are pure danger cues to
your mammalian brain
danger cues our young are vulnerable for
longer than any other species
and while our brain is developing we
know perfectly well
on a visceral level
that if we call and no one comes we die
and that's the truth
and that reality of our
long-term vulnerability
has wired our nervous system in a
particular way and creates these social
dramas wired our social dramas what the
father of attachment science john bolby
who is a english psychologist really did
which is brilliant is he linked biology
and who we are and how our nervous
system works
to our social interaction patterns to
the way we dance with other human beings
he linked
within and between he linked those two
together
in a elegant beautiful testable way
that gives us a map
to love relationships how to shape them
how to fix them how to repair them how
to keep them
and to who we are as human beings
and this map is
the way human beings have survived
through the centuries is through tuning
into others reading their cues
collaborating cooperating moving close
supporting that's the way we've survived
and
if you look at the problems facing our
world right now
we better be learning from this science
because we better be able to do that or
we're not going to survive
we've got to be able to come together
you mentioned the child crying so i must
ask you a question to scratch my own
itch and satisfy my curiosity but i may
accidentally invite you into a religious
war not with me but because i've
seen very heated debates between and we
don't have to spend a lot of time on
this but i would love to get your
opinion
on and the backdrop of this is that i'm
hoping to begin building a family in the
near future
and
i have two camps of friends
one camp
is their devout
attachment parenting
that devotees and then on the other hand
you have sleep training
and there are many different types of
sleep training but do you have any do
you have any do you have any thoughts on
because the the people so the people who
are
in the sleep training camp and there's
their arguments make sense
the arguments on both sides make a lot
of sense
in so much as what i hear is you know
attachment parenting the way they would
position it
is
this constant contact and sleeping near
or with the baby is most natural it is
in the baby's best interest if you look
at evolution
that is what's supported the people in
the sleep training camp would say that's
great but if you're not sleeping and
we're no longer living in a village we
don't have the type of support that we
had
if i don't get any sleep and my partner
gets no sleep we're going to be terrible
parents and ultimately that is going to
be bad for the baby so i don't know what
to make
of this and would
would love to get your perspective well
my perspective is
that
what attachment says is that emotional
balance when you're securely attached
and you feel safe in the world and you
know you can count on others for support
you have your emotional balance
and sometimes when we take on
huge complex issues we lose our
emotional balance i don't think to
create secure attachment in your kids
that you have to sleep with them okay i
don't think so you can if you want and i
think you have to balance things like if
you sleep with your kid in between you
all the time for three or four years
what does that do to your couple
relationship and what your kid needs is
a good couple relationship in the
parents who can cooperate believe me
that's what your kid needs so that's an
issue i think people sometimes go over
the top they take the good sense and the
science of attachment and they turn it
into rigid life rules which i think you
have to
make your own rules there
i think being emotionally responsive to
your kids is the key and for them to
know that you're there for them is the
key doesn't mean you have to always show
up in the same way and you have to be
constantly available for me i don't
think so on the other hand
i do have a visceral reaction
to sleep training
i would like to suggest
that when you do sleep training your
child does not calm down and learn to
rely on itself
what your child does is numb out
and what your child learns is that no
matter how i cry nobody will come
from my point of view that's a bloody
disastrous lesson for any child to learn
so i have a huge bias against now again
it depends on how it's done and it
depends on what else is happening so
let's not get too judgmental here but
why not let's get judgmental um i think
i think it stinks so if that's a
religious war i'm on the attachment side
because
it seems to me that the sleep training
thing
feeds into a myth that we have that is
so dangerous
the myth is about self-sufficiency
and regulating our own emotions
and the bottom line is the only
self-sufficient human being is either
numbed out on some drug or dead
we're not wired for self-sufficiency and
shutting down and numbing out is a
fragile strategy you can't keep it up
for your whole life
it shatters under any kind of pressure
so
i'm saying it glibly because this is an
interview but what i just said to you i
can give you research studies to back
that up okay i'm not just saying it
so
no i don't think
sleep training
on the other hand i can remember i
adopted my son
he was a premature and he came home he
was the tiniest little thing he scared
the hell out of me he was so tiny
and he had something wrong with his
digestive system and for the first 18
months of his life he would wake up
every two hours at least but maybe
sometimes 90 minutes
and
the only thing that would help is that
one of us would go in
and sing to him and talk to him and rock
him
for
10 15 minutes and put him down
and
we got into the habit of that and we did
that and we accommodated to that we
thought about having him sleep between
us
but we usually slept at that point we
adopted him
very soon after we got together which we
were incredibly lucky so we adopted him
about a year after we got together and
so we slept pretty entwined
so we didn't really think it was and
also he was so tiny at first i didn't
think putting him in the middle i felt
like god i'm gonna crush him if i turn
up so my husband's a big man oh we're
gonna crush hit this little one so
we didn't do that and then it changed
and it was fine my daughter was totally
different very shortly after she was
born she went to sleep you know
regularly went to sleep at same time at
night slept through after a few months
and providing you gave her all kinds of
hugs in the morning
she was this happy little clam so it was
different so i understand that parenting
can be hard
i think for me
it's the hardest thing i've ever done
for one thing is a moving target you
accommodate to your child then your
child changes you think wait a minute
like i just figured it out and now
you're changing you've become good lord
you've become an adolescent i don't know
what to do with this you know my son
turned in from this wonderful bubbly
charming delightful little being into
this
stroppy
judgmental
moral person who was pointing out how
wrong we were about everything i thought
you know who is this person where did
this guy come from so parenting is hard
and
if you take the social implications of
attachment science
we should be supporting our parents
like crazy we should be teaching people
how to have good secure relationships we
should be teaching them about
relationships educating them we should
be having more leave for parents
we should be supporting the basic unit
of our society which is our family
we don't seem to be that keen on that we
seem to be more keen on supporting
economic security or corporations
so i don't think we support parents
enough
and
maybe
that needs to change
maybe our understanding of supporting
human families
needs to change
i mean attachment has changed parenting
it's changed the way we see our children
it's changed the way we see their
emotional needs we understand that to be
emotionally alone traumatized as a child
we need to apply that to adults because
in that sense we never grow up
attachment goes from the cradle to the
grave
it's just very basic things like i talk
in one of my books somewhere about that
i think it's love sense
there's a movement called nobody dies
alone
where people get together in certain
cities
and their commitment is to go in
with somebody who's dying
and who has no
human figure to be there with them and
simply be with them
at their most vulnerable moments
and
for me
that speaks to
the fact that maybe one day we could
have something called a civilized
society
a civilized society would not let anyone
die alone a civilized society would
support families and support parents
help us learn how to parent
so i don't think it's just the couple
who are stressed i think it's the
demands of our society you have to go
back to work at a certain point whether
you're a parent or not there's no
accommodation in most workplaces for uh
parenting
was it the prime minister of new zealand
who bought her baby into the parliament
i thought yay lady
whoa
that is like yay
you know she brought her baby into the
palm that takes
guts i think so good for her but
boy
i can't even imagine that happening and
i'm
obviously you can hear i'm english i was
gonna say i've heard stroppy from my
friend from new zealand but you don't
seem to have a kiwi accent nor do you
seem to have an ottawa or canadian
accent no i'm from england i came to
canada when i was 22
but you never kind of lose the accent
but i cannot imagine even today a woman
prime minister walking into the british
parliament with a baby
and you know holding that i i would love
that i think that would be i've that
would be progress for britain for me
anyway but never mind
sorry i got off track there that was
that was there no this whole podcast is
about freely going off track when
when necessary i would like to ask a
very specific question and it may be a
dead end i don't know but i was doing a
bit of reading
on eft
and
there was a phrase that stuck out to me
which related to micro interventions so
the wording of this so the wording of
this is micro interventions from
rogerian models of therapy such as
asking evocative questions
now i like evocative questions so this
drew my attention
what would be an example and what are
micro interventions from rigerian models
of therapy okay such as evocative
questions
exactly evocative questions focus on the
process of how you're experiencing not
the content so i would say to you
tim what happens to you
when you sit and do interviews with
crazy people like dr sue johnson
and she she tells you stories that have
you move into your own softer feelings
what is that like for you tim and you
might say
oh i don't know i said well what happens
in your body tim can you tell me a
moment when you felt that rush of
emotion you say oh well it was when you
said this oh so that's the trigger
and i'll help you put your emotions
together with evocative questions and
reflections and i'll say so when you
heard me say this that was important for
you that stood out and you started to
feel a lot of feelings can you help me
what happened in your body say oh well i
felt this tightness across my chest
and i felt like i wanted to cry
and then what did you say to yourself
i said to myself my goodness
that's just how i felt when i remember
feeling that way when i was three years
old
and i say i understand
so i'll reflect it again i'll hold it
for you i'll specify it i'll ask
evocative questions i'll get you to stay
with the experience and then i'll say
what do you want to do when you feel
that way
and you might say
i want to stop it i want to get out i
don't want to feel any more of that
right now i want to shut it down
i want to stop the feeling say okay so
you want to run yeah and we've put your
emotion together in a safe specific safe
way
people can deal
with emotions that when they make sense
when they're acceptable to when there's
another human being they're accepting
them and when they're made specific
we can't deal with big vague huge
overwhelming
problems we just want to run away from
them so i'll use evocative questions
i'll use
reflections i'll use repetition
to help you stay with that feeling i'll
use an image
you know if you said to me
there's fire across i can remember one
client who said
it's like walking into a fire when you
ask me to turn and open up to him i can
tell you that i'm afraid i can look into
your face and tell you because you're
just a silly therapist you don't matter
to me much
actually that's what i said i said
that's because i'm just a silly
therapist and i don't matter too much
and she said yes that's right so i said
so i can tell you i can tell you about
my fear but when you ask me
to turn
and tell him about my fear
you're asking me to walk into a fire
and i knew that this lady
she was a trucker
there was an accident in front of her
truck and she got out of her truck
and she walked into flames to pull out
the trucker who was trapped underneath
the truck in front of her i realized
that this is an enormously powerful
image
and
if i want her to move more into it if
she can handle it if she can't handle it
i'll stop
but if i want her to move more into it
and i think she can handle it i'll say
let's stay with that image
it's like fire fire burns fire is
terrifying
you're telling your partner
it's too hard for me i can't i can't do
this right now it's too hard it's like
walking through fire
to turn and open up to you i just can't
do it and she says yes that's right i
say good tell him that
now create
i'll clarify the emotional music
help her with it help her accept it
and and you know and then i'll i'll help
her move this into a into into a drama
with another person and by the way when
we do individual therapy
we've just started to really teach efit
which is emotionally focused individual
therapy there's a book coming out next
month of september on that
when we do individual therapy we still
do this
but we use the representations inside
people's heads
so you have a cast of characters inside
your head so do i
i very thankful
my main attachment figure when i was a
child was my father
and i'm very aware that all through my
adult life especially through moments of
failure
moments of joy
key moments
i can hear my father's voice my father's
still
a reality for me right he's i carry him
inside of me and that's what we do with
our loved ones and we talk to them and
we have these dramas with them so if i'm
doing individual therapy
i might use these same reflections and
evocative questions
instead i'll say
you planned every interaction with your
mother you planned it for hours you
planned how to go and ask her for a hug
you planned right right
so can you see that little girl who
always got
smacked and taken back to her room and
left in the dark
can you see that little girl sitting on
the bed by herself
what would you want to say to her
what would you like to have been able to
say to your mum and she says something
like
i tried so hard mom i tried so hard but
i could never reach you
was it really my fault was i really such
a bad little girl
i just think you weren't a mum
you weren't a mum to me
say good
what does it feel to say that she says
that feels different
i've never said that before to myself
i've always said i didn't plan enough i
wasn't a good enough little girl
aha so can you say that again can you
see your mom what's your mom look like
in the chair close your eyes she closes
her eyes yes i see her say oh what do
you see on her face she says she tells
me she's tired she doesn't have time
you know she's tired and she's working
three jobs and you know i should just be
quiet and go to bed and stop my
grizzling stop me that's what she's
telling me
and what do you want to say to her i
want to tell her mom that's not fair
that's not fair i'm just little
and i can never reach for you i can
never reach for you you're not a mum
you're not a good mom to me i need a mum
and i say how do you feel about that she
says i feel fine
that feels good that feels different
then she emails me after the session and
says you know sue the sessions with you
are hard so i don't understand why i
sing all the way home
and it's because she moves
in the session she moves out of her
obsessions addictions with not eating
addictions for planning
anxiety she moves and so she gets
exhilarated because she starts to feel
more whole as a human being
some of the cliches we have about love
are really awful
misinformation
but one of the cliches that's really
true
and that this is true in most religions
is that when we're loved we grow and
expand
we grow we find more resources inside
ourselves we find more strength inside
ourselves
we're better at problem solving when
we're safe and secure and we feel we
matter to others and that they have our
back
our potential and our resources come out
now again i'm having such fun talking to
you i'm not sure i answered your
question oh yes it was about micro
interventions and things like reflecting
and evocative questions you gave you
gave a number of examples yes and
i i like to
think of it as as much conversation as
as interviews so even if the interview
is just a cue to take us in a different
direction that works for me i want to
come back to
some of your evocative questions though
because
i wrote them down because they
i think will be helpful for me
and
they were follow-ups to the question of
what someone is feeling so when i said
that the hypothetical was asking me how
i felt
when you said certain things in the
interview that was the example which
could be a real one and
then i would answer that and then you
had follow-ups such as what did you say
to yourself when you felt that or what
did you want to do
yeah when you felt that way
but i want to go to the initial question
which is how did you feel or what did
you feel in your body and
i have a little bit of experience as a
client with something called the hakomi
method
yes
the question of how you feel and what
you're feeling in your body comes up a
lot and i feel
for reasons known and unknown that i
have a very poor
which is surprising to me very poor
vocabulary when it comes to identifying
bodily sensations
and i'm not aware of much
outside of for instance almost every
time i would be asked
what i was feeling in my body whether it
was sadness anger
you name it it would be tightness in the
throat or tightness in the chest and
that was really
all that would come up for me yes were
these two options maybe some tension in
the forehead and i'm curious what you do
when you have a
client
who
really
can't come up with more than one or two
answers to that question what do you
feel in your body
maybe that's not a problem but i i felt
kind of ridiculous because when i've
done some couples work with
my girlfriend who's extremely
kinesthetically aware and very
self-aware she always has this rich
landscape she can describe and
she closes her eyes and she's so
specific and i'm like you know what it's
just the throat again tightness in the
throat and i feel kind of ridiculous and
i don't feel like it gives me much to
work with but how would you
respond to that word salad that i just
threw at you well you have to put it in
context i mean the point is when i go in
to something like that there's always a
specific thing that's happened a
client's told me a story or is feeling
something in the moment or is having a
specific emotional reaction or
if i'm working with couples there's a
piece of drama going on so there's
usually a specific trigger
and the thing about attachment science
is it gives us a map
to our emotional needs vulnerabilities
feelings it gives us a map
and
what i think it's a relatively simple
elegant map so if you say to me
i hear you that you have a more limited
vocabulary there's a good reason for
that you were brought up as a man
in north american society you weren't
taught to look inside and
pay attention to your emotions and
develop a vocabulary your girlfriend was
taught to do that it was acceptable for
her and so women have more language
the bottom line is though
you are human beings so you have the
same
basic emotions we talk about six basic
emotions
and you have the same basic
physiological responses so if you said
to me sue i don't know how to talk about
this that's great right that's two i
don't know how to talk about this all
that happens to me is
when and then it's specific when i hear
that tone in her voice
so what's the trigger when i hear that
tone in her voice
all i know is
that i just go tight
i just go tight
and i just stay there with you and i say
ah
so help me what do you hear in her tone
well she's irritated with me and you
know
she's going to be irritated with me and
nothing i say is going to make any
difference right
oh
so in your in you hear her tone and you
say i've already blown it
i've blown it i've blown it again
and when is that right he says yes
that's what i say to myself i've blown
it she's irritated with oh my god you
know now we're going to get stuck in
that thing i've blown it again you say
uh-huh and you feel this tightness it
says yes
you help me with the tightness it's like
you shut down
because this is
it shutting down you say yeah it's like
shutting down sue so i say uh-huh it's
like shutting down because there's
something here that's dangerous isn't it
then if you're a regular guy
you say something like no it's not
dangerous i mean you know i'm not like
really worried or anything yes you are
okay
you're just being a regular guy right so
i say oh
all right
it's not dangerous it's just a bit this
gentleman said i loved him he said it's
disconcerting
i said oh
i said oh it's disconcerting he said yes
it's very disconcerting i understand so
i say so let's go over this again so
then i go over it again when you do this
happens you hear this in her voice and
then your body does and it's
disconcerting and there's something here
disconcerting could you help me
it's like you don't know what to do and
no matter what you do it's not going to
be right he says yes
he said hmm when i feel that way it's a
little bit alarming isn't it he says yes
it's alarming i say oh
so when you feel this tightness in your
chest it's a lump you lead people in the
point is you lead them into their
emotions the point is i know where i'm
going
and so does every good eft therapist i
know where i'm going because i've got a
map and so
attachment gives us a map to how we
dance together with the people we love
where those dances go in terms of
outcome it gives us a map to our own
vulnerabilities
and emotions it tells us how supremely
sensitive we are
to signals of rejection or abandonment
by other people and that this
sensitivity is wired in there's nothing
weak or
strange or
we've framed these vulnerabilities in
very strange ways
very unaccepting ways
some of the ways we've talked about love
have been so misleading
but when you help people have the words
and there aren't that many words
there aren't that many core emotions
there aren't that many
ways to dance with a loved one
you can basically reach from them when
you're vulnerable you can shut down and
numb out and shut them out or you can up
the ante
and get anxious and demand all kinds of
responses from them that's about it
they're the main moves in the dance of
love and they can all be useful at times
but if you get stuck in one of the
negative ones like blaming and pushing
and demanding
and upping the ante to try and get the
other person to respond or shutting down
and withdrawing
that generates a dance that ends up in
disconnection and more anxiety and more
problems for both of you what would be
an example of upping the ante i
understand the phrasing as it applies to
poker but could you give us an example
of that oh i think the ante is what i
did with my description of my husband
and me
where instead of turning and saying
i'm missing our conversations i say i
guess you're tired again you're tired an
awful lot these days i guess you're
really tired
so listen to me you know i'm pushing
and foolishly what i want is for him to
turn and say
oh well
have i left you alone i'm so sorry yes i
do want these conversations but of
course i'm using a club so i'm smacking
him to get him to respond and the
trouble with that one is
the smacking pushes him further away and
that's one of the ironic things as human
beings
that sometimes when we love people
we're so unable to really reach for them
or know how to reach for them the way we
do try to reach we push them further
away how do you work with
or help someone work with
anger so you have a couple
and you're working with them one partner
says whatever they say
and then the other and then you ask the
the other partner
how that makes them feel when they hear
that and they're like it pisses me off
i've heard this a hundred times god damn
it when are we gonna this should be open
and shut case or whatever it is it could
take a million forms well most people
start there
so i say so could you help me
when your partner says this that's hard
for you to hear
that doesn't really make sense to you
and you just say here we go again
and you get angry i say
and then i'll stay with that because
underneath the anger before the anger
there's some sort of threat
there's some sort of
a threat going on right it pisses me off
because that's not what i do
right that's just the way she sees it i
don't do that you know she tells me
right so i said okay so it pisses you
off because from your point of view
you're trying really really hard to be a
good husband yes
and from your point of view she somehow
picks on this one thing and it kind of
proves that you're not a good husband
yes
and that makes you really really angry
it does and that must be very very
difficult to hear
yes
it is
what happens to you when you hear that
i don't want to hear that i'm a failure
all the time okay
ah
so in the moment before the anger
what you hear is
you hear your wife saying
you're failing
you're a bad partner
did i say that um well um
yes
lots of therapies teach that emotions
have to be controlled and contained and
got passed
we don't do that we honor emotions we
take people into them listen to them
help them hear the key messages about
survival and what they need that are in
them
and then take them through them
and if you look at a couple at the end
of eft
they're much more emotionally balanced
and when they feel vulnerable or hurt
they're better at dealing with it
securely attached kids in all the
research studies there's thousands of
studies on
infant mother attachment child parent
attachment there's hundreds and hundreds
of studies on adult attachment now when
you look at them all
they all basically say
we need this connection with other
people we need it
and we have these incredible
sensitivities and there's only so many
ways of dealing with them and there's
only so many emotions that come up the
main one that people are dealing with
when they get stuck in fights or
incredible distance is fear
fear of rejection fear of abandonment
fear of disconnection
fear that
i don't really matter to you
i'm really on my own in life
and that
intimidates us all we all know
that that is
disempowering for us
we all know on some deep visceral level
how much we need others
and the strongest among us
can accept that
and learn how to connect you know one of
my most fascinating
characters in history is winston
churchill i find him completely
fascinating i've read all these books on
winston churchill winston churchill had
the most horrible
childhood relationships he had a father
who was
mean and blaming and
rejecting and
distant and he had a totally distant
mother who was
too busy
having affairs with the king and having
wonderful parties you know they sent him
to boarding school and he would write
these letters that just break your heart
like dear mummy
would could you possibly possibly make
it to the one
this big event once a term and come and
she wouldn't even reply to his letter
ugh
so winston churchill grew up deprived
but i don't know how he managed it
sometimes human resilience is amazing
but what he did as an adult was he
created a bond with his wife
and all the evidences all through his
life he relied on that bond
and that when they got into a fight this
man this powerful man
you know who sort of
took all these impossible stands in his
life i mean and what he would do
apparently is if they got into fights
he'd go and he'd sit down outside her
bedroom door and say things like are you
mad at your winnie
so he knew how to somehow he knew how he
found a way to reach for her and she
responded enough that he had this
secure connection because they were
british british upper class so they
still slept in separate bedrooms which
is just kind of weird but any from me
from my point of view but they did that
now my class consciousness is coming out
here so
do you have any favorite
books or if you were to recommend a
resource or a book or a place to start
for people interested in learning more
about winston churchill do you have any
suggestions there's a wonderful i think
it's called the last lion it's a
biography in three volumes of winston
churchill but it takes it from childhood
until him him dying
and it's fascinating fascinating i love
it in terms of books i just read
what happened to you
with oprah winfrey and bruce perry
and bruce perry both of them are
splendid
i love bruce perry he's a
child and adolescent psychiatrist so he
comes at attachment science in a
slightly different way than me his work
dovetails with us totally brilliantly
and he says all the same things about
how emotional isolation is traumatizing
and how sensitive we are and how to grow
human beings he says all the same things
that's one recent one that i just read
you know it's funny i just came home and
literally that book is sitting on
one of the dressers
so i think my girlfriend just bought
that book so it's it seems like she and
i are having complimentary explorations
at the moment which is great
and the book that you named you actually
got it right the last lion by william
manchester the last lion box set
it is a three volume set and
has average of five stars out of five on
amazon 260 reviews so
seems to be well liked what i love about
it i think i love winston churchill
because
from my point of view
he was a successful human being
in that he
he was always honest to himself he was
always winston he was always he took
huge risks
even though some of those risks made him
massively unpopular there were periods
of time he was hated in the house of
commons you know his peers
despised him criticized him
he was creative he was always honest he
was always who he was i love that he
used to go up in the blitz everyone else
used to go into the shelters he used to
go up on the roof
and watch the blitz as it was happening
okay in the first world war
all his upper-class
colleagues
if they were in the battle at all they
were way behind the lines in a nice
hotel somewhere winston gave up being a
member of parliament and asked to go
into the trenches he said he wanted to
see them
he wanted to see what they were like he
wanted to be there in the trenches
and mind you he took his butler with him
which most of the men in the trenches
didn't have a butler but um nevertheless
man i would love to hear the
conversation with the butler on that
decision yes so probably the butler
didn't want to go into the trenches but
he was a risk taker he had huge
integrity he was passionate
he stayed with that passion even though
there were long periods of time he was
completely rejected socially he was true
to himself and he was passionate
and i think he was one of the few human
beings who could have led england
through the second world war and made it
i don't know who else could have come
forward to do that so i find him
fascinating
i find figures like him that have
courage and
stand for something
and even when the prevailing winds are
going the other way
um i always find that fascinating
do you still dance tango is that
something that you still pursue i still
does tango and kovid has been
so awful
and of course the parallel with couple
relationships is obvious you know when i
first started to learn tango my tango
teacher would be teaching me and i
suddenly say things like stop i gotta
write that down
because it would be relevant for therapy
i mean
tango is about attunement
and so is love tango is about standing
up
moving with somebody changing weight
with somebody
tuning into somebody and there's a
safety check there there's a can i find
you
are you going to respond to me are you
there
can i feel you
and then if the answer is yes if
sometimes you go through the motions the
answer is no and you go through the
motions you do the steps
but if it's a good dance
you find the other person and it's like
oh there you are there you oh i can feel
that ah
and we tune into the music at the same
time and we start to play
and there's a synchrony there that is
happens in hold me tight conversations
happens in good sex
happens in
its play and synchrony and it's two
human beings impacting each other
responding to each other sending cues
tuning into the queues there's something
intoxicating about it so
when i realized the parallel
i was not good at it i want to tell you
my teacher who was not big on empathy
said something like um
why do you want to teach tango
you're uncoordinated you don't have any
balance you're not 22. i said thanks
very much you know i'm in my late 50s
actually so thanks very much for that
comment at the time i learned tango
right said you're you know this is going
to be very difficult for you
and i said well then shut up and start
teaching me because i'll just
i'll just work harder at it than
everyone else that's all he said why do
you want to do it i said because there's
something here these i get these little
tiny moments
where we're both moving together to this
beautiful music that are just
joyful he just looked at me and said
all right then
but you're gonna have to work really
hard
there's so many parallels i can remember
one lesson when i said to him i got
angry and i said
you're not sending me any cues
just for people listening this happens
all the time these arguments between
tango couples they get into these
bickering fights all the time so please
continue so this is this so this is my
teacher right and he says he's trying to
teach me this new move and i say
you're not saying anything
you're not sending me any cues he says
the cues i am sending you are enormous
i said what are you talking about you're
not sending me any cues you'll be like
you'd be just being ridiculous so bless
his heart he does what we do in eft he
says
feel it
he moves his shoulders slightly to the
right about a millimeter can you feel
that see no
he says do it again feel it can you feel
that
no
he does it 20 times i
oh
and sometimes what that's what you have
to do in couple relationships you have
to slow everything down and give people
time to listen to a new thing they're
not used to hearing or can't take in you
have to slow it down
you know and you can't just do all this
stuff fast so then i go
oh oh i got it
and then he says right and he says now
follow it and i turn
this happened all the time the parallels
in relationships and they were the same
so i go to tango lessons and get
completely
enthralled
intellectually emotionally physically
i adore tango but i have to say
i probably shouldn't say this on air um
oh no you're allowed please do i find
mostly i find it's easier to dance with
women
and there are many women leaders
and i can't figure out why that is but i
think it's
because women
have had to learn to tune into other
people in order to survive socially
over the years
they've had to do that so maybe it's a
little easier for them
but i find
with women leaders often or maybe i just
feel a little safer with women leaders
maybe that's what it is i don't know
but
often i find it easier to dance with
women although i've had some amazing
male partners too one of the big
arguments in my marriage was that we
started dancing tango and then my
husband said he wasn't going to do it he
didn't like it so i won't tell you what
sue johnson
said to that
it was not it was not a positive evening
because
that was like you can't do that to me
you know i i need a partner and he
basically said it hurts my back i'm not
gonna do it and so that was very
difficult but we got through it
he goes hiking
and i don't particularly like it when he
goes hiking up mountains all by himself
it scares me
and from quite a while he didn't
particularly like it when i would go off
to the malonga
you know and as he put it insist on
dancing very very close to other men for
hours
i'm dancing tango the just fact that
it's very very close is just the way it
is right anyway
one of my close friends
does not dance he does not dance but his
wife loves ballroom dance and dances a
variety of different styles and
i remember one saturday it might have
been a friday that was it was a saturday
he said here's my wife's evening and he
sent a photograph that she'd sent him
and she's in this
really sleek super sexy dress
all done up looking gorgeous dancing
with this latin guy they're face to face
you know sweating all over each other
and then he said here's my evening and
he sent a photograph and it was a table
with arts and crafts with like a half a
dozen kids going totally batshit crazy
and uh
he uh he painted quite a picture for
himself and i just want to backstep into
what you were saying about tango it's
making me really want to dance again i
haven't danced in a very very long time
but for people who don't know
so a few things on the gender split
in argentina a lot of the tango began in
the port town of buenos aires with men
dancing with other men it's actually
very common very very common and even
now you can find and i trained because
oftentimes in the classes when i was
there we wouldn't have enough women or
you wouldn't have enough men so women
would dance with women men would dance
with men
and
there are two brothers ah i can't recall
their names somebody else
yes who they're incredible do you know
the name do you remember the name no
they're amazing oh incredible yeah if
somebody goes to youtube and just
searches you know argentine dancing
tango brothers or something like that
you'll see the two of them dancing and
it's a very
aggressive masculine
almost violent type of
tango it's incredible to watch
and you're bringing back so many
memories for me i remember being at
different milongas like nino bien or
sunderland sunderland and all these
different milongas and
what struck me so much when i went to
some of my first milongas which for
people wondering start really late and
end really late in argentina they often
don't even really get going until
midnight it could be a tuesday it
doesn't matter and i went in and i
noticed that many of the best female
dancers danced with their eyes closed oh
yes and the complexity of the movements
were one thing and you watch and you
just you just can't understand how it's
possible for someone to dance so deftly
with such subtlety so quickly with their
eyes closed but on top of that as a
beginner you walk in and you think to
yourself these two must have been
practicing for months and months and
months years and years together and then
you find out it might be the first night
they ever met it's
all
cues and improv it's just
mind-blowing it's so impressive and it's
the synchrony
that kind of physical and emotional
synchrony moving with the music
that synchrony
elicits joy in human beings it's the
reason why birds have mating rituals
swans move their necks in unison they do
this ritual they move into synchrony you
know it happens with mothers and
children they move into synchrony the
little child opens his eyes the mother
leans forward and opens her eyes wider a
synchrony in tango synchrony in love
making between lovers sinkery and hold
me tight conversations
this is our nervous system buzzing
and saying yes
this is belonging
this is safety this is joy and our
nervous system buzzes with this and it's
so rewarding
i tried to explain to my husband why i
needed to keep tangling at one point
and i said
when i danced with i was used a woman as
an example you know when i dance with
mary ellen in 12 minutes of dancing i'll
have you know four straight moments of
this
incredible synchrony when my brain is
out sitting in a chair looking and
saying how are you doing this i don't
understand you doing this you don't know
any of these moves and what happened
there i don't i understand how this is
going because your prefrontal cortex
isn't subtle enough it's like you're
picking up on attunement and moving with
someone and this is what human beings
can do we can read these cues incredibly
fast we have these mirror neurons in our
brains that pick up
the cues from somebody and feel them in
our own body and uses the basis of
empathy
and it's a beautiful thing and so yeah
when i first went to a to malonga i
stood there and said
how do they
do this
this is the most beautiful thing i've
ever seen and it's impossible i don't
understand i want to do it
i want to do it so
but it takes a long time
and in a way
it's kind of the same discovery that our
couples go through where
you know somebody will say to me
i never felt this before i never knew
you could feel this i never i never knew
people could have these kinds of
conversations i never knew
that i could talk about my feelings like
this i never knew
that i would talk about my feelings and
i would look up and see in the other
person's face
that they wanted me and that they wanted
this and you know
someone will say
you don't have to
keep problem solving or taking care of
everything you don't have to keep
solving all the problems what i want is
you
if you tell me you're overwhelmed by
this problem that's what i want i want
the connection with you and the other
person goes i've had people say
what did you say
and the person has to repeat it like
four times says then they look at me
with this blank look and i say
you can't take that in
you've never imagined a drama with
another human being where somebody might
say that to you and they go
no
and then they weep
because in the end
what none of us can bear is the feeling
that we're alone
and that we don't matter to another
human being that's
you know and our world doesn't talk much
about that
you know it when i first heard that you
wanted to talk to me i thought why does
he want to talk to me he's into business
and he's into teaching people how to
make money and he's into and then
somebody said no no
he's into success
and what helps people feel successful
and i thought oh well that's okay
because from my point of view success is
about being really alive and being
really live is about being connected
with others and knowing that they are
our greatest resource and that that's
where we are most alive whether we're
dancing tango making love responding to
our child
it's such fun to talk to you you're fun
i never know what questions you're gonna
sometimes you ask quite intricate
questions that's really fun
you're fun too you're fun too and i only
have a few more questions because i know
we're getting
not necessarily two time but we're
definitely
covering a lot of ground you've
mentioned sex a number of times good sex
and this is important to many if not all
couples
and i'd love to
pose a situation and hear how you might
approach it and that is
couple who
love each other dearly they actually do
not seem to be shutting down at least
obviously
they've been together a long time and
maybe the
passion the fire has simply
died down somewhat they're more
i don't want to say roommates because
that has a pejorative
sound to it but they're good parents
they love each other they maybe still go
on dates and so on but for whatever
reason that sexual spark
is not as strong as it used to be
how would you approach
that situation that couple what's always
interesting to me about sexuality and
sexual conversations is that our
world arguably
i mean sex is everywhere now compared to
even say
20 30 years ago
theoretically we're more open and
we're more accepting about sex we're not
so restrained and all that so what's
fascinating to me is it seems to me
that
people
couples have an incredibly hard time
having a conversation about their sex
lives and that's still true and it was
true 30 years ago and it's still true
now
and i think it's because
in sex people are literally naked
they are vulnerable
and they don't know how
to even begin that conversation so what
we do is we create safety in the
relationship we have to look at the
relationship and we walk into that
conversation one of the big
conversations about that one is there's
a lot of evidence now i think it's
really good research
about the difference between male and
female sexuality
and there's a lot of evidence that
women
respond differently to physiological to
sexual cues a woman can be
physiologically aroused for example by a
sexual cue if you look at her in an mri
study i think this was by a man called
gilath
basal canadian researcher also talks
about this there's quite a few people
i think chisholm talks about it so the
evidence is a woman can be
physiologically turned on and if you ask
her if she's turned on she'll tell you
no
whereas with a man physiological arousal
and experience just goes together like
that they have an erection they say i'm
aroused with the woman there's something
else that seems to happen what seems to
happen
is that the woman's physiologically
aroused and then her prefrontal cortex
cues in
and her prefrontal cortex the theory now
is from these studies that her
prefrontal cortex basically checks out
the safety of the relationship
which makes sense because women are i
mean let's face it if you look at the
sex act
women are vulnerable they're naked
they're going to open their body they're
going to be penetrated by a stronger
animal this is a basic thing so it's
almost like women check out the
relationship and the connection and the
safety before they then feel
they actually let themselves feel
aroused and so women take longer often
to be aroused somebody said to me what's
the best foreplay i can do with my wife
i said well have you heard her talking
here
i think what she's telling you is the
best role play you can do with your wife
is to talk to her and share with her and
turn up well basically i didn't say turn
up emotionally but you know that's where
i was going you know like
show her who you are you know stand out
on the dance floor open your arms you
know it's like and so women have a
slower pace often women have responsive
desire they don't start off from lust
they start off from being open to their
partner or being curious they don't
start from the same place as men and
people haven't known how to talk about
that
and so men and women miss each other and
also men men talk about how the classic
story is that men start talking about
how they want sex
but time and time again when we're
dealing with a couple sexual
relationship if you really go in and you
really stay there
it's not just about orgasm because let's
get real if it's just about orgasm men
can give themselves an orgasm very
efficiently and so can women there's
amazing vibrators out there okay so
that's not an issue so but it's not just
about orgasm because if you listen to
the man who says who's always badgering
his wife for sex
what it comes down to is
on an emotional level and he has a hard
time getting there
he wants to feel wanted
he wants to feel desired
and in that men and women are the same
and when that somehow a couple give each
other the message
i don't particularly desire you
one way of dealing with it if you have
other good things in the relationship is
to just shut that part of your
relationship down and numb it out
but you can bring it alive
but you have to be able to be aree you
have to be able to take some emotional
risks you have to turn and say
you love this kind of sex well i want to
tell you that for 20 years i've hated it
i hate it
one lady said
you think it's the sexiest thing in the
world to come up behind me and bite my
neck
i hate it when you do that
and he says
what are you talking about and she just
didn't feel safe enough to turn and say
i hate that and here's why i hate it
people hang back they shut down but you
know passion is about
feeling
safe enough to be completely absorbed in
the experience and let it take you over
passion is about full engagement
and we talk about it it's all about
novelty it's not all about novelty
novelty can turn passion on but the
research is clear from people like
lauman at the university of chicago the
people who have the best sex have it
most often and who feel most enthralled
find it most thrilling are people in
what you would call safe long-term
relationships
because then you can let go you can
passion is about erotic play you can let
go and play and lots of couples have
sort of put that part of their
relationship off to the side they
haven't known how to tune into each
other they haven't maybe accepted their
own emotional needs they haven't known
how to talk about it so we simply create
safety and we open it up for them
and they start to
share and talk
and find it again
they have to have
acceptance somebody has to be able to
say
i was bought up a catholic
there's some part of me that can never
quite accept
my own sexuality
and some part of me just needs you to be
dominant to demand it of me and then i
can get turned on well she needs to be
able to tell that to her partner because
he's always comes on to her considerate
and low-key he doesn't want to offend
her in any way well that it doesn't work
right so people have to be able to
examine the way they dance together and
share and then they can find each other
and it's the same with
sexual problems you're in hold me tight
one of my favorite stories i've got it
in the book of the man who has erectile
dysfunction
and the trouble is not that he has
erectile dysfunction the trouble is he
freaks out every time he has erectile
dysfunction and shuts down and
withdrawals from his wife and then she
gets upset and feels rejected and
abandoned so the whole relationship
starts to go to hell when they can talk
about it connect with it
and i suggest that you know
sometimes i think we call his penis
george i can't remember now that i say
sometimes george goes for a little nap
and it's no big deal if they can stay
connected with each other and she can
help wake george up you know she knows
how to do that they laugh and they play
and there's no problem after a while
because they deal with it differently
because they have this safe connection
but the trouble was the sexual problem
was
interfering with their safe connection
and everyone was playing it safe and
being nice to each other and keeping
everything calm
the thing is what we've learned about
attachment science can help us shape our
emotional relationships
and our sexual relationships it gives us
a map for how to do that
and
it really
challenges the old cliche
that love and
passionate love has a best before date
it really challenges that
love has to be remade and passion isn't
the same over 30 years but it can still
be made and remade and there are times
when people are more tuned into that
than others but anyway that's we could
talk about sex forever so that's a
there's some huge topics here tim they
they are we may have to do around two or
three to talk about
let me ask a follow-up which is
sort of the
the opposite end of the spectrum with
respect to one example you gave so the
one of the examples you began with was
that of
female physiological arousal often
preceding psychological arousal
and i'd be i'd be curious to know
because
this seems to be common at least among
many
men that i know and many men who
write to me in some fashion
that
they're extremely attracted to their
partner for a period of time and they
see this in
relationships one after the other for
six nine months whatever it is and then
it's not that they stop being attracted
to their partner they still can
objectively and subjectively look at
their partner and find them sexy and
attractive but they just do not have
as much sex drive as they would like at
a certain point in the relationship do
you have any
not necessarily advice for them but
could be advice but thoughts on how to
approach that so not a situation where
the male is demanding or hoping for more
sex although that might be the case but
in fact a situation where the woman has
more sustained sex drive than the male
well that's an interesting one i don't
know i mean we condition men to think
about
physiologically their sexual need and
their sexual response is very available
to them compared to women and it seems
to be immediate
and we condition men to accept their
sexuality and to accept sort of last and
to expect a certain amount so i don't
know i think it depends and i may have
been prejudiced because the cases that
i've seen in that situation
have usually been that there's another
whole element going on which is that
there's a certain point in relationships
where people realize
that
they're vulnerable
and
that this person holds their heart in
their hand
and for some people
before that the infatuation and the
excitement and the novelty and the
all that stuff
can carry them forward
and then there's a moment when it's kind
of like the bonding scenario kicks in
and they realize they're vulnerable
this other person can hurt them and that
they need this person they need certain
responses from this person and for some
folks that is exceedingly difficult
and they can't even really put their
finger on what that's about
and they start to shut down
and
i can remember one very dramatic case of
this
where this guy pursued this woman and
adored her and everything was great and
then they got married
and literally they got married
and
she became immediately pregnant and was
very ill with the pregnancy so she was
kind of she kind of withdrew so from his
point of view he took the ultimate risk
which he said he was never going to do
and got married and the minute he did
that
from his point of view this person
became unavailable he completely shut
down his sexuality
completely he numbed it out
except in his mind in his mind she was
still the most attractive woman in the
world he still you know had all kinds of
active fantasies i mean he still had
lust he just shut it all down and that
was all about the emotional reality of
him
suddenly coming up against this reality
that he needed her he'd risked
and suddenly she wasn't there and of
course
that was a very familiar experience for
him from his childhood
and
then she got angry of course because he
wouldn't you know he shut down and the
whole relationship went bad so
these emotional
scenarios can be complex you have to ask
what's going on
i think there's also a point in couples
lives with especially in our present
world where they get caught up in
parenting caught up in tasks
caught up in what we've decided is
success which is working longer and
longer hours being on your devices all
the time
literally
they don't pay any attention to the
relationship and to the emotional music
and to the connection and then they
suddenly expect it to be there in bed
well
it's not
because it all sort of goes together so
we don't find it that difficult to help
people
if they want to go through those blocks
we don't find it that difficult to help
people
deal with their sex life differently
with problems or to reawaken that
passion in fact what we find is when
people start having hold me tight
conversations
we don't even talk about sex their sex
they tell us their sex life improves
because they start to be able to play
and take risks with each other and tell
each other things they've never been
able to tell each other before and
accept their own sexual desires or
sensitivities in a new way and share
them
so then this openness this emotional
openness and responsiveness turns into
physiological openness and
responsiveness
it's very hard to be open and
physiologically responsive when you're
afraid and guarding yourself all the
time
yeah those those two sound
almost entirely mutually exclusive
well i would like to if you're if you're
open to a few more minutes just to hear
your description since people will want
to explore this more of hold me tight
online the relationship enhancement
program
what brought you
to develop that and what can people
expect if they engage with that what
brought me to develop it was insanity
because um
it was a story of my life yes it was an
insane amount of work okay
and um
i just i got obsessed with the fact that
we
from my point of view this science and
all our work had
created this enormous possibility for
people to have much better relationships
much more secure families
better mental health and and somehow
people weren't getting the message i
just became
so disconcerted by that
that i said we got to do a whole bit we
got to do an online program we've got
this is the only way it's going to reach
people so
my
colleagues bless their hearts
i seem to have this ability to go in and
say insane ideas and then people pick
them up and suddenly we're working for
about four years on this huge project
so we created this the online program is
it's got little talks it's got three
couples going through the process
you see the three couples working it's
got little bits of music little
exercises
it's customized we put a huge amount of
work into it
i don't know of any other program like
it out there
especially not based on
tested interventions and a clear
science of what love relationships are
about we get very good feedback on it
i'm very encouraged by the fact that the
military
the u.s military i believe and the
canadian military are using it now and
the government of british columbia where
i live on the west coast of canada
has just bought a number of them i think
they're going to give them to first
responders whose relationships are
having a hard time
the heart institute is talking about
creating an online program because they
have a live program in their hospital
now in ottawa so i'm very encouraged by
the fact that institutions are picking
it up but it's supposed to take the hold
me type book
and turn it into a live engaging online
program that you can do with your
partner
and
there's some research on the educational
program based on hold me tight there's
no research yet on the online program
but we're still working on it we want to
for example the three couples who agreed
to be filmed through this we just took
the first three couples that came
into the studio in ottawa and did it
with me did those conversations with me
in a very snowy winter so when i look at
them now
it looks a little dated those three
couples there's a young couple
a couple that are facing all kinds of
other difficulties and an older couple
they're still useful you can still see
but we've added we started to add
conversations like we have a black
couple
right now
with a black facilitator talking about
that and talking about issues with
racism and how that impacts your
relationship we're trying to put new
conversations in you can see a couple go
through it you can hear me talk about it
you can learn about it you can hear the
stories about it you can do exercises i
mean it's really designed to lead you
into being able to have your own hold me
tight conversation
and i think
well i'm a bit crazy about all this but
you know we need books and we need
online programs we need to educate
people about relationships
it's insane
that we have all this science and
understanding
and that we are not
sharing it and putting it out
so that we can have more positive loving
cooperative relationships and more
secure families from my point of view
it's insane so we created the program
and we're going to keep adding to it
and
hopefully institutions will keep picking
it up and for a while we did it and
online wasn't popular and so it just sat
there and i thought what do i have to do
to get this stuff out there but it has
picked up quite a lot people are hearing
about it
i think this conversation will help at
least with a handful of people
yes
so that's the hope
and this has been so much fun
dr sue johnson you are a blast to talk
to and
i will of course
add
show notes with links to everything and
people can
find you at dr sue johnson d-r-s-u-e
johnson
j-o-h-n-s-o-n-drsjohnson.com they can
find the hold me tight online program at
hold me tightonline.com
you're on all the social i'll link to
those in the show notes and people can
find you on twitter at dr dr that's at
dr underscore sue johnson
is there anything else that you would
like to
say any closing comments any requests of
my audience anything at all that you
would like to
add before we close this first
very enjoyable conversation for me at
least i don't want to speak for you
the only thing that occurs to me is
to say on a personal level that
one of the enormous realities of my
childhood
was that i understood that my parents
loved each other
and they fought continually
that was something that distressed me
puzzled me alarmed me
freaked me out
and i think
way back there somewhere sitting on the
stairs in the dark listening to the
fight
i somehow felt that
there had to be a better way
there had to be a better way and i think
the other thing was i adored my father
and in the end
the fact that marriage didn't work
destroyed him whereas the second world
war didn't destroy him all kinds of
other things didn't destroy him but the
fact that that marriage didn't work
destroyed him so i knew
how important
relationships were and
for me
when i started to see couples and i
started to see patterns
and then i started to link it to
attachment science and i suddenly
realized that
there was a way
that we can understand love that we can
understand and shape our most precious
relationships
that is just something that i just feel
like
we need so desperately
it's so important on so many levels that
i just want people to know
that you don't have to fall in and out
of love and that
even if you've never seen this kind of
bonding
you can find it we can show it to you on
a video we can tell you a story about it
you can do it
it's wired into us
that there's incredible hope for
relationships
because
more and more people are living alone
more and more people are giving up on
love relationships
normal people are
saying things like monogamy's impossible
doesn't work
this just brings up
despair in me because it's like we have
this
we have the way forward
and we're not using it
so that's why i do things like make
crazy online programs that take me four
years and
anyway it's been amazing fun to talk to
you
thank you it's been a great time and i'm
so glad that you were able and grateful
that you are willing to
carve out the time to have this
conversation i really think it's going
to help a lot of people this has been
incredibly helpful for me personally
i've taken a ton of notes i have a lot
of things to follow up on i'm going to
have some very very
i think some very bonding and engaging
conversations with my girlfriend and
this has inspired me to
further seek out the tools that help us
to shape
the love that we need and want instead
of just waiting for some miracle to fall
from the sky or a disaster to fall from
the sky and it's
it's very enabling to hear you speak and
to
get a better understanding of your work
and certainly i can only imagine to
engage with the work that you've
developed so i'm very grateful
to you for the time and for the work
that you're doing i think these tools
are
invaluable and
never more needed certainly than right
now i think that word despair that you
mentioned is something that a lot of
people have become intimate with in the
last
year but that the last year has really
just magnified i think an underlying
despair that many people already felt i
agree and i'm so glad that we were able
to take the time together so thank you
very very much and perhaps if you have
time in the future we'll do a round two
but we'll
no need to rush that
but really really tremendously enjoyed
this conversation so thank you again
you're welcome lovely to talk to you
lovely to talk to you and you asked
wonderful questions so i appreciate that
thank you so much
oh my my pleasure entirely and for
everybody listening
we'll have links to everything in the
show notes as usual at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and until next
time thank you for listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email where i
share the coolest things i've found or
that i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up i
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
headspace headspace is your daily dose
of mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations in an easy to use app now
you might ask yourself very reasonably
there are 2 000 plus apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps advanced
in the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research headspace is backed by 25
published studies on its benefits 600
000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million downloads so people keep telling
you to try meditation and you're like
when would i do that when would i
possibly have time you should check out
headspace if you have 10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers a really light lift and a lot of
features to keep you going which is part
of the reason that i've used headspace
for years now so whatever the situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation for you need
some help falling asleep headspace has
wind down sessions their members swear
by and for parents headspace even has
morning meditations you can do with your
kids headspace's approach to mindfulness
can reduce stress improve sleep boost
focus and increase your overall sense of
well-being and it really starts with
very very simple practices and if you
look at my case for instance i just went
through
one of the basics
today with the
co-founder andy think it's put a [ __ ]
could be pretty comb i'm not sure but
former monk turned into co-founder of
headspace has the most soothing hypnotic
voice imaginable and i did a three
minute meditation something like that
it's easy it's fundamental and it always
puts me in a better space so i'm going
through the basics even though i've
meditated for years i'm going through
the basics once again and i would
suggest to anyone that they consider
starting there headspace makes it easy
for you to build a life-changing
meditation practice with mindfulness
that works for you on your schedule
anytime anywhere we all want to feel
happier we all want more peace and
headspace is meditation made simple go
to headspace.com
tim that's headspace.com tim for a free
one month trial with access to
headspace's full library of meditations
for every conceivable possible situation
you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace this is the best deal
offered right now for headspace so check
it out go to headspace.com
tim today
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep and i'm a
member of that sad group temperature is
one of the main causes of poor sleep and
heat has always been my nemesis i've
suffered for decades tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nozzle but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device called the pod pro cover
by eight sleep it's the easiest and
fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced but most user-friendly
solution on the market i polled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools for
sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this so i used it here we are
add the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping as cool as
55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit it also splits your
bed in half so your partner can choose a
totally different temperature my
girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32 faster reduce sleep interruptions
by up to 40 and get more restful sleep
overall i can personally attest to this
because i track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys you can get
two hundred and fifty dollars off of the
pod pro cover that's a lot simply go to
eight sleep dot com slash tim or use
code tim that's eight all spelled out e
i g h t
sleep.com tim or use coupon code tim tim
eightsleep.com
tim for 250 off your pod pro cover
[Applause]
you